[музика]
коли я думаю про їжу я думаю про
привілей я думаю про культуру їжа
об'єднує людей і надає їм сили особливо
під час кризи у найтемніші
часи
[музика]
Я думаю що ми ще не дуже розуміємо що
відбувається і що сталося тут але я
думаю що цей інцидент є точкою
неповернення Ізраїль до цього моменту не
є тим Ізраїлем який ми матимемо
відтепер я йотам доктор ресторатор
власник ресторанів хакім Док і Абі які
знаходяться в тель-авіві мій брат асаф
шеф-кухар ресторанів ресторан хакім - це
ізраїльський ресторан який був
заснований з метою відзначити усе хороше
що є тут в Україні від ізраїльського
менталітету до ізраїльської їжі та
музики ізраїльське суспільство схоже на
мозаїку складену з різних типів людей і
те що тут відбувається Люди які працюють
з нами у ресторані справді складають цю
мозаїку або принаймні більшу її частину
У нас тут є і представники гбтк +
спільноти І Шукачі притулку з судану і
еритреї та ізраїльські
араби і це змушує нас робити більше ніж
просто ресторанні справи хакім - це не
лише ресторан це свого роду організація
яка має соціальну роль щоразу в останні
роки коли виникала криза чи потреба
ресторан одразу зголошувався допомогти
чи то під час ковіду коли ми роздавали
людям їжу чи то під час найшаленішого і
найважливішого протесту який ми бачили
тут за останній
рік останній клієнт залишив ресторан у
п'ятницю ввечері о :35у ночі А о 5:30
ранку в суботу сюди влучила ракета це
було пряме попадання за 50 МТ від мого
будинку без будь-якої
[музика]
тривоги скло кухонного вікна ледь не
розтрощило наші обличчя Ви відчуваєте
себе безпорадним ми з сім'єю поїхали до
наших батьків щоб подивитися що там
відбувається ми розуміли що ми у стані
війни у суботу ввечері ми вирішили що в
неділю відкриємо ресторан щоб
підтримувати людей ми просто почали
обдзвонювати знайомих постачальників
інших рестораторів та друзів які можуть
прийти і допомогти стати
волонтерами
допомагати з пакуванням приготуванням
їжі завозити її туди куди потрібно на
кордон у лікарні і за кілька годин у
цьому заході брали участь приблизно 200
[музика]
людей продукти харчування надходять в
госпіталі солдатам які перебувають у
польових умовах та евакуйованим
сім'ям
[музика]
[оплески]
Мене звати алон Мені 38 Я музикант із
тельавіва Я волонтерюю вожу цю їжу тому
що це те що я можу зробити це дивовижна
країна люди просто приходять готують їжу
просто від душі тому що хочуть
[музика]
підтримати у WhatsApp виникло багато
груп які організовується щоб допомогти в
будь-якій сфері будь-яким способом
постачання розваги для дітей у
притулках вони пересилають повідомлення
про те що потрібно людям чи різним
армійським частинам містам
сім'ям кожна людина тут знає когось Кого
вбили чи
викрали йому вдалося надіслати нам своє
поточ місцезнаходження і раптом ми
побачили що він прямує до гази з цього
моменту він перестав відповідати на
телефонні дзвінки у кожній історії на
Facebook бачу що хтось когось шукає Бо
рідні не знають Чи ця людина мертва жива
чи зникла безвісти її викрали в суботу
відтоді від неї жодної
звістки багатьох людей вбили там були
трупи і
там Це дуже важко це дуже близько до нас
ця різанина яку ми пережили вони зробили
з нами щось
[музика]
жахливе і для людей сидіти вдома з цим
нестерпно
[музика]
треба було приїхати на базу десантників
У чому
проблема просто вони поїхали на операцію
там нікого немає але я заповнила нову
форму для інших хлопців які хотіли б
отримати доставку поблизу аждода Добре я
поїду туди Чудово дякую Дякую
Бувай ми привозимо їжу солдатам
запасу кожного колишнього солдата можна
призвати на військову
службу тому люди залишають свої сім'ї
роботу повсякденне
життя військові яких відправляють на
бойові дії - це наші друзі наші рідні Ми
маємо їх підтримати багато солдатів
знаходяться у польових умовах без їжі та
напоїв
За перший день ми вже встигли відправити
20 000
[музика]
порцій травму від того що вони зробили з
нашим народом неможливо
описати і я думаю що всі люди які зараз
тут емоційно переживають цю ситуацію
деякі люди впадають у депресію деякі не
можуть перестати плакати дехто дуже
злиться ми всі відчуваємо що наша довіра
до державних інститутів підірвана і гнів
на уряд неможливо описати вони руйнують
наше суспільство країну економіку
безпеку єдність нашого
суспільства прийти і попрацювати можна
для того щоб
[музика]
відволіктися бажання допомагати один
одному Я думаю що в цьому полягає магія
цієї
історії Солідарність - це одна з
цінностей яка робить нас ізраїльтян тими
ким ми
[музика]
є
люди які приходять сюди просто беруть
Усе в свої руки спілкуються один з одним
і створюють усе що потрібно ми Ізраїль
це Ізраїль і так буде і
[музика]
надалі цей репортаж ми підготували лише
за кілька днів після атак хамасу У той
же час жителі гази опинилися у повній
блокаді Ізраїль припинив усі поставки
їжі води ліків та електроенергії більше
мільйона людей намагалися втекти кордони
були
[музика]
закриті це викликає у мене жахливі
спогади Я з України з Києва коли Росія
почала повномасштабне вторнення у мою
країну я змогла вибратися тоді шефкухар
Євген Клопотенко теж виїжджав із Києва і
замість того щоб готувати страви високої
кухні він запустив громадську кухню для
переселенців на заході укра
але зараз він повернувся до свого
ресторану у
[оплески]
Києві до мене приїжджає безліч людей з
усього світу для того щоб скуштувати
найкращу українську кухню в світі тому
запрошую до мого
ресторану Всім привіт Мене звати Євген
Клопотенко Я український реформатор
культури харчування Ну і дехто мене
називає батько борщу Давайте я вам
приготую найкращий борщ в вашому житті
[музика]
коли людина споживає борщ перший раз
Вона відкриває для себе Україну
[музика]
Це так працює Я займаюсь тим що я
останній рік годую всіх дипломатів які
приїжджають в Україну укрзалізницею тому
що в укрзалізницю вони проводять 8 годин
дорогою до Києва всі Світові лідери і
між народних організацій і перші особи
вони всі я їх всіх годую в потягах і
звичайно я їм даю нашу їжу я їм даю борщ
і звичайно що коли відбувається
голосування за надання Україні допомоги
чи ні звичайно що приймається рішення
багатьох факторів економічних
різних-різних Але існує ще й культурний
Фактор чи тобі подобається ця країна А
якщо ти поїв гарну їжу тобі Ну
подобається ця країна Коли ти приїжджаєш
в країну і гарно іїси Ну тобі трошки
якось до неї стає тепліше і крутіше
до того щоб мені зробити українську
кухню популярну мені треба було я навіть
не знав що робити але коли Путін мені
допоміг він зробив так що люди виїхали з
своїх місць і як би це жахливо не
звучало але завдяки саме цьому я
допускаю що десь ну мільйонів 500 людей
завдяки пономасштабному вторгненню
скуштували українську
кухню
[музика]
кухня на жаль зараз ще не не супер
розвинена бо ми самі ще для себе не
визначили в Україні що таке українська
кухня бо багато і радянських страв і
пропаганди і всього і тебе солодкий борщ
від Та та Ну все посередині між тим що
висту те що любить па моїм батькам я
сказав що Якщо ви будете їсти олів'є я
від вас відмовлюся і все і в це є просто
ще один із елементів пропаганди що у нас
на Новий рік треба готувати ось ці
салати бо так готувала Моя бабуся А моя
бабуся готувала бо її змусили нічого
іншого не
було гастронаціоналізм - Це абсолютно
нормально їсти українське і світове але
тільки не радянське на Новий рік ще буде
стояти поелія буде стояти німецький
Салат буде сти цейзар і паста - це
ідеальний Новий рік це круто і класно
можна навіть без українських страв але
головне відірвати себе від цієї соски
Радянського Союзу бо вона як метастази
вона постійно буде продовжувати жити
поки ти їх не
видалиш а класичного рецепту борщу не
існує е класичного тому що в Україні
кожна родина Вона готує по-своєму борщ
тому я використовую Закарпатське варення
ну це такки закарпатські виварені сливи
під назвою леквар а потім додаю сметану
і Ти отримуєш кисло солодкий баланс з
димком це те що я вважаю дуже
конкурентно навіть буде в світі
[музика]
піч - це є той секрет найголовніший який
відрізняє мій бощ від всіх інших коли
ставимо бощ до печі він там мліє він там
томиться і він так дуже повільно
насичується ароматом диму А українці всі
обожнюють коли щось копчене або з
ароматом
диму
[музика]
ми просто унікальна країна яка має свої
традиції але ці всі традиції були
розмиті в рамках Радянського Союзу і
коли я побачив
що в Словенії борщ продають як
російський суп Я коли побачив що МЗС
говорить що борщ - це типа для всіх і це
типа російська страва ну мене вже це
почало трошки бісити
коли ми внесли борщ до Юнеско від
України Ми зібрали десь 500 сторінок
документації для того щоб подати ми
об'їздили всю Україну ми знімали робили
відео як три
покоління бабуся донька і онука вони
мали готувати борщі ми зафільмували я як
ця традиція передається що вона має
спадковість
[музика]
Я тепер завдяки тому що борщюнеську люди
і знають що в нас є своя
[музика]
Кухня ми достойні бути частиною світу бо
ми є частиною світу а все життя нас
принижували і казали що ми ніхто і тому
це ця перемога - Це ще один такий
важливий камінь в формування нашої
[музика]
нації Всім привіт я Таня я режисер Я
знімала це все про борщ і давайте
спробу О Боже БН Якщо чесно я не
очікувала що він настільки смачний і це
Ну піч зробила свою справу Блін це
просто неймовірно супер
[музика]
борш хотіла б і я спробувати той борщ
коли я залишила Україну то опинилася в
Берліні і стала частиною mнay kitchenн
української спільноти зосередженої
навколо їжі та культури ми подаємо борщ
на наших заходах А нещодавно
відсвяткували нашу першу
річницю музика та їжа - найкращий спосіб
познайомити когось із
[музика]
культурою mнay kitчен дає відчуття сім'ї
відчуття спокою відчуття безпеки якого
іноді бракує в цей час особливо в
незнайомому місці в незнайомому місті
Тобто Це нова нова країна нова
мова особливість того що ми сьогодні
приготували ми зробили цікаві чорні
вареники вони всередині з активованим
вугіллям що виглядає і красиво і дуже
корисно для травлення Так значить як це
робиться розказуйтеце значитьнього
івенту в тому що ми зібрали не
максимально традиційні страви
української кухні це борщ власне
абсолютно веганський з веганською
сметанкою тому що ми хочемо бути
інклюзивні Ми хочемо щоб всі люди як
вегетаріанці вегани чи навіть міясоїди
могли пригоститися нашими стравами
Січ Вау я тебе почула отак от це ви бачи
на mн kitчен я кухар Я вчу людей
готувати українські страви і готую сам
ой-ой-ой щоб воно все в і сильно зажимай
по краям просто от я думаю що дуже гарно
що ти можеш завдяки стравам відчути у
іншому місті у іншій країні відчути себе
як
вдома Мене звати Михайло я
е жив у городі Маріуполі народився
вчився працював і зараз я
тут ми сиділи у дворі з моїми друзями
мої друзі їх батьки
е Ми готували їжу Як завжди Це було на
багатті ставили воду кип'ятили на чай і
в якийсь момент ми розуміємо що наряди
бомби падають дуже близько до нашого
місця Ми вийшли на подвір'я і зрозуміли
нас звідси живими просто не випустять
тут зібралися стерти просто все з лиця
землі Ми зрозуміли що треба тікати в
ітогі нас забрали на евакуаційному
автобусі і відвезли в тимчасово
окуповані інші міста Ми виїхали
окуповане Росією місто місто це було
безменно і там ми проходили фільтрацію
де у нас знімали отпечатки пальців
проводили жорстокі допити і перевіряли
наші телефони на вся усілякий контент
пов'язаний з
війною далі я опинився в Росії коли я
зв'язався зі своїм другом він мені
сказав що він може мені надати прихисток
у
Берліні
коли я тільки сюди приїхав я
познайомився з Владом і уже через
тиждень він запросив мене на перший mн
kitчеchen і там я вже здобув нових
друзів тому вклад mнy kitчен в моє життя
просто не нереально
[музика]
переоцінити за рік ми стали великим
комюніті за рік насправді дуже багато що
змінилося Ми почали займатися
культурними проектами також Тобто ми вже
ми вже втілили декілька перформансів
концертів
також культурна мова Коли я можу без
слів описати
що таке
[музика]
Україна
[оплески]
проект який Я приготував називається
missing Se що означає вкрали море це
шість фотографій найкрасивішого місця в
моєму місті це Азовське
море
[музика]
в мене насправді вкрали море це моя
персональна трагедія через війну росіяни
просто забрали моє місто мій дім і я
тепер не можу туди
[музика]
повернутися
питання повертатись або залишатись і
воно кожного дня
є Я хотів би приїхати в Маріуполь
подивитись на ті вулиці де я зростав де
я був малий потім дорослішав і На жаль я
не маю такої
змаги хочеться повернутися звісно назад
в Україну
і я не знаю як довго буде буде тривати
війна я хочу бути оптимістом але не
вдається тому просто зараз фокусуюся на
тому що можу робити конкретно
[музика]
я для
мене саме гарне майбутнє на яке я можу
розраховувати це мати можливість
повернутися додому моя родина живе зараз
в окупованому у Маріуполі У мене немає з
ними постійного зв'язку вони весь час
знаходяться у небезпеці і тому мені дуже
важко Мама розказує Моя бабуся завжди
чекає мене
у біля вікна і чекаю коли я
повернусь моєю МР єдиною наразі мрією є
те щоби мати змогу повернутися додому
щоб я міг я і мої друзі і всі інші
українці могли знову повернутися додому
і просто обійняти своїх рідних як і
[музика]
[оплески]
раніше я теж цього
хочу незважаючи на те що я вміла
готувати ОЖ з дитинства у понеділок
команда кухні показала мені багато
цікавих секретів про те як зробити мій
бощ ще смачнішим Наприклад якщо додати в
нього трохи лимона то смак буде ще більш
вираженим і цікавішим на наш ювілей ми
зварили понад 100 літрів борщу який
закінчився за кілька
годин для Ельміри та Ернеста їжа - це
набагато більше ніж справа смаку вони
Кримські татари і змушені були залишити
свій дім після російської анексії у 201
році у ресторані Крим вони знову можуть
відчувати свою ідентичність і зберігати
традиції коли ми тут вивішуємо прапори
це наша форма щоденного
протесту Мене звати Ернест сулейманов а
це моя дружина Ельміра
сейтаметова ми Кримські татари і
власники цього татарського ресторану
Крим у
Варшаві
що називає
Крим ресторан розташований навпроти
російського
посольства Я знайшов це місце випадково
і коли я його побачив то відразу подумав
що було б круто відкрити тут крихітний
шматочок вільного
Криму
у радянський час усі Кримські татари
пережили депортацію наші батьки
народилися в Криму у 1944 році їх
насильно переселили з Криму в Узбекистан
ми народилися в гетто наша ідентичність
завжди була пов'язана з Кримом і ми
завжди чекали коли зможемо туди
повернутися це сталося після розпаду
Радянського
[музика]
ми були категорично проти окупації проти
референдуму ми були
активістами деякий час боролися а потім
зрозуміли що за нами
стежать тоді ми просто змушені були
виїхати спочатку жили в Києві а
у
Варшаві очеви
звичайно Ми сумуємо за
домом найбільше Ми сумуємо за
батьками бо вони вже в такому віці що ми
мали б бути поруч і доглядати за
[музика]
ними
за два місяці буде рік як ми відкрили
свій
ресторан наша кримсько-татарська кухня
кардинально відрізняється від
української ми використовуємо багато
овочів таких як перець і
баклажани зав'язати мішок можеш
зав'язати зелену цибулю
також
тут можна відчути грецький Балканський і
турецький вплив усе це
[музика]
змішалося ми вклали у ресторан любов до
нашої
Батьківщини це такий вільний шматок
Криму ми посли кримськотатарської
кухні Татарська кухня є регіональною
кухнею українихня украї
то есть традици це традиційна Татарська
страва
[музика]
чебуреки мені хочеться думати що коли
Чуєш слово чебуреки відразу згадуєш
кримських
[музика]
татар Наш ресторан зараз як центр куди
приїздять Кримські татари які виїжджають
з Криму щоб їх не забрали в російську
[музика]
армію коли вони приїжджають то для них
це місце теж як
дім
ми дуже раді що Люди приходять нас
підтримати і поляки і українці і люди з
інших
країн вони можуть почуватися тут як у
вдома Незалежно від того чи це відома їм
їжа чи вони лише знайомляться з нашою
[музика]
кухнею наша ідентичність як кримських
татар в Україні та українців у світі
нічим не
відрізняється
і Ми впевнені що ми звільнимо
Україну зво зволь
[музика]
украї звільнимо Крим і повернемося до
себе в наші
[музика]
домівки
foreign